nous l'avons vu hier soir le coût de la
rentrée 95 devrait augmenter en gros 2
4%
en plus des cahiers du cartable des
crayons il faut encore habillées ces
chers bambins qui se montre de plus en
plus exigeants sur la dernière mode sous
les préaux reportage eric bastion andry
sort dans quelques jours marion sera la
plus belle pour aller à l'école
la mode vêtements pour la rentrée
scolaire c'est traditionnel elle reste
très classique mais on peut aussi
trouver la touche originale qui fait que
même gamin on sera in plutôt que out
cette année retour sur la mode sixties
seventies couleurs vives jupe trapèze
veste en mouton et col roulé maman à
ségou et c'est elle qui décide
cette tendance années 60 elle correspond
plus à une demande des parents que les
enfants réellement c'est très marrant
parce que les gosses en fait se fondent
dans le moule et ne demandent pas
d'originalité ils ont envie d'être comme
le petit court terme la mode rentrer à
l'école et ce jusque dans les
fournitures scolaires le placer ou six
fois plus cher qu'un autre mais avec la
tête du mannequin préféré de chut c'est
le succès garanti à l'école succès aussi
en magasin la mode fait vendre le placer
top model s'arrache même si certains ont
des goûts personnels lequel je préfère
toujours au rayon des fournitures tous
ces cartables se vendent bien mieux
lorsqu'on nicole une marque célèbre de
vêtements des douze ans les types faire
comme maman
le fait de pouvoir acheter à un âge très
avancé c'est à dire en 11-12 ans un
produit qu'est la marque gagne mais qui
n'est pas du vêtement qui a un alibi je
verrai utilitariste parce que c'est pour
l'école pour le lycée leur permet dès
leur plus jeune âge de pouvoir profiter
de cette marque que normalement seuls
leur maman pourrait avoir une grande
soeur
mais avant de défiler aux côtés des top
de la mode il faudra des filets la
semaine prochaine pour rentrer en classe